at 22 10 years later so 1971 I was
following the markets and between
graduating from college and going to
graduate school I was clerking on the
floor of the New York Stock Exchange
and
um in that intervening period there was
a lot of aspirations a lot of
um desire and you know to go to the Moon
to eliminate poverty to make equality in
the United States and so on so in that
early era when there was Kennedy and and
that made me an optimism and then but
during that 10 years the fact is that
there was a lot of borrowing of money a
lot of deficits back then
um a gold was money and money as we know
it was like checks in the checkbook that
would go get you the gold you can turn
in your paper money for gold but gold
was the real money and because the
United States had borrowed a lot more
money than it um had it wrote a lot more
checks than it had gold in the bank and
so on August 15 1971 when I was clerking
on the floor of the New York Stock
Exchange I watched on television as
President Nixon
defaulted on the obligation to pay gold
for for the cash he went on and he said
you know they won't you won't get the
gold and I of course he didn't say it
that way he said it in a way where it
sounded like there were speculators and
so on and he had to do it but to get the
gold and so on the floor of the New York
Stock Exchange I walked on the floor of
the New York Stock Exchange and I
thought the market was going to go down
a lot because after all this is a big
crisis the money as we know it ends and
I couldn't have been more wrong it went
up a lot and um what happened was I
never went through a currency
devaluation before because in my
lifetime there was no currency
devaluation so that's the first time it
happened so I went back and I looked in
history and I found the exact same thing
happened on March 5th 1933 except rather
than the television and Nixon it was the
radio in Roosevelt and he made the exact
same announcement and have the exact
same effect and at that time I learned
two things two big things I learned that
first
that many things that never happened in
my lifetime seemed surprising at the
time and that I needed to study things
that happened before my lifetime to
understand them so when certain things
are happening like right now there are
certain things that have never happened
in our lifetime before but happened many
times in history so in order to
understand them just as you said in the
beginning I need to understand the
patterns and even more than the patterns
the cause and effect relationships
behind the patterns so that mistake
taught me that I'm not needed to
understand history